[Applause]
guys listen
we can't do everyone's ideas how are we
supposed to chant no justice no peace
while we're taking a vow of silence i
know a way
whoa what school are you from attention
[ __ ] and losers
i have an announcement this meeting is
over because it has come to my attention
that
every single one of you sucks ass
this school lost whatever made it great
the day the douglas kids showed up
and everyone started pretending to be
fake ass friends even when we clearly
hate each other
that's not true tamika's my friend oh
yeah right you don't really care about
her
yeah she does and i care about her too
and if i make fun of her bathroom habits
it's just because i'm jealous of her
regularity
you're all fooling yourselves if you
were really friends you would have
agreed to the walkout
instead you're just sitting around like
a bunch of garbage bags full of potato
salad stuffed into gap outlet sweaters
and i'm looking at you cult this was a
birthday present from greg
i knitted it for him and he looks
amazing in it
oh my god
keep booing me that's me eating your
booze it feeds me you basic
[ __ ] that's enough listen i think
lexi's wrong
i think we do care about each other and
we are good friends
now it's one o'clock and i'm walking out
who's with me
are you gonna be okay
you